[Music]
ah beautiful shot of the white house
welcome back to cbs mornings the white
house is getting a new covidzar
president biden announced that dr ashish
jaw will take over when jeff zion steps
down next month now this comes as a
number of new covet cases in the u.s
plunges but china and other parts of
asia and europe are seeing an uptick dr
ashish jaw is a dean of browns
university school of public health for
now we should say congrats is in order
to you dr jaws you start your new job
next month
very very excited about this for you
and for us actually because you've been
a regular guest here but this is what
i'm wondering how you're feeling because
word was just announced that they've
just stripped some of the government
funding in the covet bill so what's it
like taking over when you're hearing
your budget's going to be cut number one
and what's your top priority
good morning gail first of all thanks
for having me back i'm delighted to be
back um look the pandemic isn't over as
much as we all wish it were right we
still have work to do
and the president has laid out a plan
for how we're going to prepare for
future surges how we're going to
prepare for new variants if we get those
and so my job is to help implement that
plan to make sure that americans are
ready
and i am confident that congress is
going to support that uh because we
really got to do this we got to be ready
for anything that mother nature throws
at us and that's what's in the plan and
that's what i plan to work on uh
implementing for the american people
uh dr john when it comes to these new
variants and sub-variants the ones that
are out there are there ones that you're
concerned about should we expect what
we're seeing in europe a spike to be
showing up here in the weeks ahead
that's a great question so ba2 the one
that's starting to circulate uh in
europe it is actually here as well about
25 percent of of infectious rba2 look
what we know about ba2 is it's a little
bit more transmissible but our vaccines
work really well particularly if you're
boosted so anybody who's not gotten
boosted
needs to do that i think if we do that
we may get a small surge but it's going
to be kept to a minimum we're going to
be able to get through this
the key here
is to watch the data and to make sure
more people are getting vaccinated and
boosted
you mentioned boosters last night
moderna asked the fda for emergency use
authorization for a fourth
vaccine that would be a second booster i
know that's the cdc's decision but how
are you feeling in general about the
regularity or possible annual dosing up
of uh of vaccines
yeah it's a it's a great uh question
look we have always wanted to be guided
by data on these things we were when the
first booster was rolled out
we've got to see what the data says on
this my guess based on the data that's
out there right now
is i can imagine for high risk people
that a second shot will be useful but
again let's look at the data let's have
the fda and cdc make its decision
and see where we end up with with the
evidence on this
and really let's try to be guided by
that
dr jai you've been very public about
your belief that the way through this
pandemic is for vaccinations to increase
globally so how do you see your role
playing a role in that
yeah if you think about every variant
that has hit us right alpha delta now
omicron these have all arisen from
beyond our shores
for both moral reasons and just for
getting this pandemic under control we
have got to get the world vaccinated so
the president's plan is very clear on
this we that america has to lead
i plan to do everything i can to help
implement that
until we get the world vaccinated it's
going to be hard to put this pandemic
behind us
you know they're starting to loosen up
on masking do you hey what
a one how do you feel about that and
testing should we still be getting
tested
you know gail i think given how low the
infection numbers are right now we're
down what 95 from our peaks in january
i think
you know pulling back on mass mandates
right now is very reasonable i've been
saying that for several months still
believe that
we want to have plenty of tests around
for the next surge and we want to
obviously be able to be ready to put
back mass back on if we need to i
suspect we won't let's see where the
data is on that
but we absolutely need to make sure we
have enough tests available so if we see
a future surge we can get tests out to
the american people
all right dr john thank you very much
congratulations again congrats congrats
good morning thank you yes